Okay. So, good morning. Uh, this morning
we are doing the Protestant Reformation
and I'll explain to you how it gave
birth to capitalism. Um, this class it's
going to be hard conceptually because we
we're going to take concepts we learned
before and combine them to help explain
the world we live in today. So, if
there's anything I'm saying that's not
clear or um confusing or debatable,
please interrupt me. Okay. All right. So
I want to make sure that you can follow
the logic clearly. Okay. So um first of
all what I will do is is explain the
three major differences between the
protestant religion and the Catholic
religion. Okay. So let's look at
Catholic
first. In many ways the Protestant
religion is a response to the problems
created by the Catholic religion. Okay.
So there are three main characteristics
about the Catholic religion. The first
is the idea of
orthodoxy or
dogma.
Okay. So there's a set of beliefs in the
Catholic religion that you must
memorize. You're not allowed to question
it. You are not allowed to interpret it.
You must memorize it. Okay? And what
maintains the orthodoxy is the idea of
hierarchy. So
only priests and the ordained those
sanctioned by the Catholic church have
access to the Bible. Only they can
interpret the Bible properly. They are
favored by God. The pope is the is God's
official representative on earth. Okay.
So that's idea of hierarchy. The last
concept um is the idea of
justification by
works. Okay. Um and the idea here is if
you want to be saved, you have
to engage in the proper rituals. You
have to do what the church tells you.
Your actions matter more than your
beliefs. Okay. Now, as we discussed in
previous
classes, these three main concepts that
underpin the Catholic Church, they will
create problems. Okay. Um the so
justification by works, it creates a
problem
of
hypocrisy, right? The idea here
is it'd be nice if you believed in God.
It would be nice if you believed in what
you were doing. But you don't have to.
Okay? As long as you do what you're
told, you can still go to heaven. Okay?
It creates idea of hypocrisy. And
obviously, there are a lot of people who
are opposed to this. All right?
Hierarchy creates a problem of
corruption. There's no real mechanism to
prevent the priests from abusing their
powers. And as we discussed last week,
the priests do engage in a lot of
corruption and um abuses. Okay. The
problem with orthodoxy is it creates
disconnection, right? And the idea here
is that um ever since the dawn of human
history, we humans are fundamentally
religious. Our fundamental, our first
and foremost need is to connect with
God, to be with God, to work with God,
and to access God. Okay? And that's and
because of these three problems,
disconnection, corruption, hypocrisy,
there's always been dissent, there's
always been rebellion against the
Catholic Church in Europe. Remember last
week we discussed the Cathars, the
Waltians, right? So this has been an
ongoing issue in the Catholic church. So
the Protestant religion was developed in
a response to these problems. Okay. So
let's look at the three major responses
of the Protestant
religion. Okay. The first response to
orthodoxy is direct
access. You don't need the priest to
tell you what the Bible means. You can
just read it by yourself. In fact, God
wills that you talk to him directly by
reading the Bible.
Okay? If that is the case, then the
church must be fundamentally
egalitarian because if everyone can
access God, then everyone is equal in
the
eyes of God. But the fundamental demand
now is
justification by
faith. You have to truly
believe in
God. You must develop your life around
this faith in God. Okay.
So on one hand the Protestant religion
is solving a lot of problems created by
the church but on the other hand it's
also creating a lot of problems as well.
Okay so let's go very quickly over some
of the major problems. Um if it's
justification by faith it creates a
problem of
anxiety. Why?
Because how do you know you truly
believe in God? Does that make sense?
How do you really know you have faith?
You have to calculate prove to yourself
that you truly believe in God through
actions, through works. Okay? You have
to raise doubt in your mind and this
makes you anxious. It makes you antic.
Okay? So that's one huge problem created
by uh pro the Protestant religion. The
second big problem is a problem of
diversity. If everyone is equal, then
everyone can start his or her own
religion. And what we will see during
the process of reformation is an
explosion of different religions with
all they're all different sets of
beliefs. There's only one Catholic
church, but there's like tens of
thousands of Protestant
denominations. Okay. Um does that make
sense? Okay. All right.
So then with direct access you are
forced to have literacy okay you are
forced to educate
yourself all right and this is a good
thing right but it's also a problem
because if you're poor you may not have
access to education all right so this is
a problem for a lot of people and that's
why um in the beginning of development
of protestants
Protestantism most of the adherence to
this new religion are actually the
aspirational middle class. The people of
some means there are people who want to
aspire to more wealth. Okay. So this is
the basic rundown of the differences
between the Protestant religion and the
Catholic religion. All right. All right.
Um any are you clear about this? Are any
any questions so far? Is this clear to
you? Okay. All right. So now I'm going
to go deeper and explain the problems
that this new religion creates in the
minds of the faithful. Okay. The the the
faithful. All right. Okay. So the
problem that it within the Christian
religion as we discussed in previous
classes is the idea of the holy trinity.
Okay. The holy trinity. The idea of the
Holy Trinity is that Jesus
um God and the Holy
Spirit, these are different forces that
are independent of each other, but they
are equal to each other and they're part
of the same thing. Okay? So for the
human mind, the way that our human minds
are designed, it is impossible for us to
understand this concept of the Holy
Trinity. It's like saying like this pen
it is here and not here. Your mind has
to believe that this thing is here and
not here. And your mind can't do that.
Okay. Your mind has to believe in one
thing and and you it cannot believe in
contradictions. But this is inherently a
contradiction. The only way that our
mind can process this is by believing
that this is a
symbol. Okay. The reason why is that
this is something. The only way that we
can understand the holy trinity is to
believe that it is both nothing and
everything. Okay? And that's what a
symbol is. A symbol is nothing that
represents everything depending on how
you perceive
it. The problem with this is
that it creates the problem
of anxiety.
Right?
Anxiety. Why does it create anxiety?
Because again, our fundamental need is
to connect with God. And the concept of
the Holy Trinity means that we can never
truly connect with God. It is a symbol.
It is an abstraction removed from us. We
can never be intimate with God. It's
either away from us or through us. But
we can never touch it. We can never feel
it. Okay? This creates
anxiety. Before this was not a problem
because the
church stood between you the
believer and the holy trinity. Okay. All
you had to do was believe in the church
and you were
fine.
But then what happens? You get rid of
the church. Now you have to grasp with
gr try to grasp what the holy trinity
is. And again remember one of the main
um ideas of the prom religion is that
you must struggle with your
faith. You must re recognize and fully
realize your faith in God. Otherwise
you'll be condemned to hell. But as we
already discussed this holy trinity is
impossible to understand.
Okay. So this creates
anxiety. Now the thing about anxiety is
it creates um the the problem of like
OCD. Okay.
obsessive
compulsive
behavior
because anxiety
um comes about because of
confusion. Okay. What you want to do is
remove this anxiety by ordering your
physical world. Right? People with
obsessivempulsive behavior, what do they
do? They like to clean houses. They like
to buy things. They like to lose weight.
They're trying to order. The word we use
is
rationalize. They're trying to
rationalize the world around
them in order
to re reduce your anxiety. Okay. All
right. Does that make sense? Right. Have
you studied obsessivecompulsive
behavior OCD? All right. It's caused by
it's caused by anxiety. And this anxiety
forces you to try to rationalize the
world. All right. Now, there's also a
third problem in the Protestant religion
and it's the idea of
double
pre
destination. All right. Okay. So, this
is a big concept but but it's very easy
to understand.
If you remove the church because the
church is too corrupt, the problem
arises like how do you know if you're
going to heaven or not? Who's going to
decide? And so a man, a theologian by
the name of John Calvin, he proposed the
idea of double predestination. And the
idea here is this. God at the beginning
of time has already
decided. And this decision is final. You
cannot persuade him that he is wrong
because he is perfect, eternal and
immutable.
And only a few, the elect will be saved.
Only only these people will be allowed
to go to heaven. Everyone else will be
condemned to
hell. And who are the elect? The elect
are those who truly
believe that they have been
saved. O only those who truly believe in
God's mercy and God's grace will be
saved. Okay? If you think about it, this
creates even more
anxiety because how do you know if
you're one that's saved? You have to
work hard now to solve this problem.
Okay?
So let's summarize because of the
protestant religion you have three new
problems created. The first is the
individual believer cannot understand
the holy trinity but they must. That's
what the religion demands. That's the
first problem. Second problem is the
anxiety causes OCD which makes them want
to rationalize the world. It makes them
want to order the world according to
their faith. Okay, that's the second
issue. The third issue is the idea of
double pre predestination that where
which says that if you do not truly
believe in God if you have if you do not
actually figure out the grace of God
then you'll be condemned to eternal
damnation. Okay. So these are the three
major problems created by the pro
religion. And so over time okay and this
is a process that will take decades
centuries. They figure out a
solution, right? They figure out a
solution. And the solution is this. The
solution is money.
Sorry,
money. Okay. The solution is money.
That's how you resolve these three
paradoxes or three contradictions, three
anxieties. All right. So, first of all,
let me explain what money is. Okay.
money. All right. So, in the world we
are
all different. We have different pers
perspectives. Okay.
Um so each individual is unique. Each
individual is different. Each individual
sees the world differently. And this
creates confusion. This creates
problems. Okay? If I ask you why you're
in school, you might say, "Oh, I'm here
to learn mathematics." I might ask
someone else like, "Oh, I want to go to
America for college." Another person
might be like, "I want to learn." Okay,
each person is
different. Okay? But what happens is
this. If I introduce the concept of
money, what it does is it standardizes,
systemizes, clarifies and simplifies
everyone's understanding into
one concept into a coherent hole. Okay.
So let me use an experiment to show you
like why this is true. All right. So
some experimenters they gave everyone a
wine test. They put three different
bottles of wine in front of each person.
Ask each person to taste the wine and
then ask each person which wine is the
best. And most people could not tell the
difference. They were different. They
these are different bottles of wine but
they didn't know which one was better.
Okay. Then what the experimenters did
was they put price tags on each bott of
wine. Okay,
$10, $20, $50. And then when the
expenders did this, everyone knew, oh,
of course the $50 bottle of wine is
better. Okay, so that's what money does.
Man, money allows us to simplify the
world to in order to understand it.
Okay. So all our beliefs, all our
values, our judgment now is placed into
this one symbol, money. But then what
happens is we then take this money and
we reshape the world according to money.
Okay, does that make sense? Now I ask
you, why are you going to school?
Everyone's like to make money in the
future. Everyone agrees on this.
Okay, so that's what money is. Money is
a system to standardize everyone's
thought and then once the
standardization happens, it reshapes
reality into a rational order. Okay,
does that make sense? All right. Okay.
So, let's go back. Okay. Now that we
understand what money is, we can now
explain how money reduces the
paradoxes, right? Money is a way for
people to rationalize the world. You're
you're anxious. What do you do to re to
reduce this anxiety? Make money. Make
more money. Don't stop until you make
the most money.
Okay?
Then money is a way to resolve the God
issue because money is also a symbol. So
what you can do mentally is conflate God
with money. Money is God. God is money.
That makes sense to people, right? And
now because you've completed God of
money, you can now solve the
predestination problem, which is like,
oh, how do I know I have faith in God?
Because I have a lot of money. Because I
spend my entire life accumulating
money. And how do I know I'm going to
heaven? because I'm
rich. The my wealth shows that I have
true faith in God. If I have true faith
in God, then I must be one of those
predestined by God to be the elect. And
therefore, I have nothing to worry
about. All
right? And because of this, the beauty
of the system is this. It creates a
concept of capitalism.
Never before in human history have
people people believed that this is a
good thing that that you should go
accumulate money for the sake of
accumulating money. Okay? Before it was
always about accumulating money in order
to increase your social status. So
wealthy people would always spend their
money holding community fees. Okay? On
giving money to the the poor, on helping
the community. So remember Julius Caesar
when he died he was the wealthiest man
in the world but he gave a third of his
money to the poor people of Rome. He
gave a third of his money to building
parks for Rome. Okay. And the and the
the final third went to um is adopted
here um Octavian. Okay. All right. But
now what's important is that you try to
accumulate as much money as possible.
Don't waste it because if you waste it
it's corruption. It shows you lack of
faith in
God. All right? And that's why we have
capitalism because of the anxiety
created by the Protestant Reformation.
All right? And again, um this is a
process that will take centuries. It
doesn't happen right away. Okay? But
it's a process that takes centuries and
it's and it's a process that will define
the world we live in
today. Okay? Even though
today most people actually not
Protestant, most people do not believe
in double pred predestination. Most
people um don't really understand the
holy trinity. Most people don't want to
rationalize the world. We have absorbed
this mentality.
Okay, we believe that we should
accumulate money for the sake of
accumulating money. That's why we
worship people like Jack Ma, Ellen Mus,
Jeff Bezos. Even though if you think
about
it, they've just accumulated a symbol,
right? But money is actually nothing.
But we worship them because we believe
that money is reality
itself. All right? That's what
capitalism is. Capitalism is a belief
that money is reality in itself. All
right? So um I know conceptually this is
hard and this is a lot but and now what
I will do is explain historical context
explain the evidence for this argument.
But first I I want to make sure that
this argument is clear to you. This this
is a thesis. Okay. This is to this is
explanation as to why you have
capitalism
today. All right. So, um, any
questions before I explain the
historical
context? This is all clear. Okay, good.
All right. So, now what I'm going to do
is uh explain the historical context as
well as provide the um evidence. Okay.
All right. So, the cost of reformation
All right. So the process of reformation
is a
process that took place from 1517. 1517
is when a theologian Martin Luther
published his 95 thesis. His the 95
thesis is a direct criticism of the
Catholic Church. Uh the corruption of
the Catholic Church and it ends really
in the year 1648. This is after decades
of um violent warfare between the
Protestants and the Catholics. And at
this point, Europe is completely
exhausted. They just finished fighting
something called a 30 years war, which
is before World War I, the deadest war
in European history. It kills at most
about 8 million people. So all of Europe
is completely devastated. In certain
parts of Germany, which is where the war
was fought, they lost about half of
their population. Okay. And this war
ended in something called the treaty of
Westfailia, the peace of Westfailia,
which guarantees religious freedom to
everyone in Europe. And this ends the
Protestant Reformation. Okay. All right.
So again, um, historians state the
beginning of the Protestant refu
reformation to Martin Luther. Um last
week we we discussed the crusades and we
discussed how um there were um many
thinkers theologians who are post
Catholic church uh people like John
Whitecliffe Jian Hos um and they were
eventually condemned as heretics and the
rebellion was stumped out by the
Catholic Church. But Martin Luther u
he's fortunate in that he has powerful
political patrons. The various princes
of the Holy Roman Empire want more
autonomy from the Catholic Church and
Martin Luther gives them a proper
pretext in order to financially divorce
themselves from the Catholic Church.
Okay. So, as I discussed, what he's most
famous for is something called the 95
thesis, which is a direct criticism of
the corruption of the Catholic Church.
At this time, the Catholic Church wanted
to build St. Peter's Basilica, a church
in the Vatican. And they wanted this to
be a gorgeous building. So to finance
the building of this church, the um
Catholic Church sold something called
indulgences. Indulgences are basically
like tickets or um um special letters
that will reduce the punishment of your
relatives in purgatory. Okay? It's it's
basically to reduce the number of sins
you committed. It's it's it's basically
like bribing God, okay? To reduce your
your penalty. And this was a very
popular thing and allowed uh the Pope to
build St. Peter's Basilica, which is one
of the most beautiful buildings in the
world today. But as you can imagine, if
you are a true Christian, you are
insulted, you're offended,
um you're angered by the idea of this
corruption. Okay. So the 95 thesis uh or
95 sentences in which in which um Martin
Luther lays out his case against
indulgences and as such against the
authority of the church and the pope and
this is the argument he makes. Okay. So
let's look at some sentences in on so
the 36 sentence is every truly repentant
Christian has a right to full remission
of penalty and guilt even without
letters of pardon. Okay. And what he's
saying here is the idea of salvation by
faith. You don't have to spend this
money. You don't have to do what the go
what the church tells you. If you are a
true Christian, if you truly believe in
God, God will forgive you. You have
direct access to God. Okay? So he's
denying the authority of the pope which
makes him a heretic. He also says
Christians are to be taught that the
pope in granting pardons needs and
therefore desires their devout prayer
for him more than the money they bring.
Okay, this is very insult to the pope.
He's saying like the person that most
offends God in this world is the pope
because the pope is insulting God by
telling the world that that God can be
bribed by money. Okay. So, let's pray
for the pope because clearly the pope um
has offended God.
He also says,"Wh does not the pope whose
wealth is today greater than the richest
of the richest?" He's saying the pope is
the richest man in Europe. Why doesn't
the pope spend this money and build the
church
himself build just this one church of
St. Peter with his own money rather than
with the money of poor
believers? Okay? Why is he exploiting
the poor when he is the richest man in
the world? Okay, as you can see and as
you can imagine, the cho the church is
furious with him and they deem him a
heretic and they want to burn him at the
stake. But again he's protected by
powerful political patrons and they
fight a war um over this issue and it
ends with something called the peace of
Augsburg which divides um the Holy Roman
Empire Germany into uh Lutheran uh areas
where they are free to believe in
Lutheran and Catholic areas where they
still adhere to the pope. Okay. So this
is the beginning of the Protestant
Reformation.
um J Martin Luther um starts um this
doctrinal debate and John Calvin also
contributes to it by introducing the
idea of double
predestination. All right. So Martin
Luther he wants to reform the church and
and then he eventually realizes that he
needs to build another church. But John
Calvin with his idea of pre double
predestination, he's trying to he's
trying to deny the authority of the
church. Okay? He's telling people that
because God has already decided who will
go to heaven at the beginning of time
and the church is lying to you. The
church is fooling you, deluding you.
Okay? All right. So, uh he's a
Frenchman. He went to the suborn the
University of Paris. And as you can
imagine, he's deemed a heretic and he fi
and he flees to a place called Geneva in
Switzerland. And Switzerland is one of
the birth places of the Protestant
Reformation. The reason why is um there
are a lot of independent towns in
Switzerland and as I mentioned um the
first believers in the Protestant
religion are actually towns people.
That's aspirational middle class. Okay,
they want they want to be connected with
God. They want a religion that
encourages them to achieve more in life
and that's what the Protestant religion
is
about. Um there's also another uh famous
theologian that's really not not
discussed today, but he's considered one
of the three major founders of
Protestantism. His name is Eric Zingli
and he's based in Zurich. Okay. And he's
probably the most extreme of the
three. Okay. All right. So, the
Protestant Reformation, it opens a can
of worms. It opens a Pandora's box
because before the ultimate authority
was the pope who represented God, but
now you're free to believe whatever you
want. So, um there are lots of peasants
who rebelled against nobility because
they thought that feudalism was evil in
the eyes of God. Okay. Okay, so this is
a
protocommunist movement. These are
people who wanted total equality and
democracy and freedom in the world
because they believe that is the will of
God. Okay? So they rebel against the
feudal lords that kill them and then the
entire uh monarchy unite the sarcas
because they see this see these peasants
as a threat. Okay. Now there are lots of
these peasants. We estimate maybe about
300,000 joining this rebellion, but they
are not educated. They are not
organized. They have no
weapons and they have no centralized
authority and therefore they're all
massacred by uh the aostatic armies.
Okay. All right. So this is the peasants
war and this is important because
eventually we will discuss communism and
communism will be developed in response
to the peasants war. Okay. So this is
the deadliest massacre of peasants
before the French
revolution. Um 1534 is the act of
supremacy. That is when the king of
England Henry VII declares his
independence from the pope. Okay. But
because there's such a strong Catholic
contingent in England,
um Henry VII maintains Catholic
practices. But rather than have pope be
at the head of the church, he himself is
now head of the church. Okay? It's
called the church of England now. And
the relig religion is called uh England
the Anglican religion. Okay. The
Anglican religion. All
right. Um so the thing that we should
observe about the reformation is that
first of all it's extremely diverse.
Okay. There are lots of different
denominations. The Lutheran are those
who believe uh in Martin Luther. Okay.
The Calvinists are those who believe in
double
predestination. The Anglicans are
English who still follow Catholic
rituals but rather than follow the pope
they follow the king of England. Okay.
The Husides are those who adhere to Jane
Husse in Bohemia. The Unitarians are
interesting. The Unitarians are those
who deny the divinity of Jesus. They
deny the Holy Trinity. God is God and
Jesus is just the Messiah. He's just a
prophet of God. Okay? So, they affirm
the moral teachings of Jesus, but they
deny his divinity. You also have uh the
Anabaptists. Okay? The Anabaptists are
interesting as well because they believe
that to truly believe in God, you must
choose to do so. Therefore, you must not
baptize infants because when you do so,
you force children to believe in God
even though they themselves lack the
capacity, lack the reason to believe in
God. Okay? So only adults can join the
faith and they must do so voluntarily.
All right. So, as you can see, there's
tremendous um divergence. There's
tremendous diversity within the
Protestant uh faith and it still still
continues today. Okay. Every day you
have new denominations opening up
because people are interpreting the
Bible differently. The another thing
that you will notice is that most of
Protestants are actually located in
Northern
Europe, right? So the countries of
England, Germany, uh the Nordic
countries, Switzerland, they will go
Protestant. And in the south, um France,
Spain, Italy, they will remain Catholic.
The only exception is this, the south of
France, okay, the south of France, the
south of France will turn Protestant.
It's interesting for us because if you
look at a map, okay, the Protestant uh
French are heavily centered in the south
of France. And if you remember from last
week, that's where the Caththers are
also located. Okay. So, some historians
believe that um Protestantism um and
Cath and Catharism, they sort of mingle
together. They combine and became
conflated together. Okay. Other
historians believe that it's because
that culturally the south of France
because it's um it's it's like
surrounded by mountains. It's always
been culturally
independent of um the rest of French.
They speak a local language called uh
proven which is different from uh
French. Okay.
um these Protestants in French in sorry
these Protestants in France um they're
mainly the middle class they're
extremely well educated they become very
prosperous and they're joined by the
nobility and as such the king of France
and France is right now the most
powerful country in Europe the king of
France sees him as a threat and so what
he'll do is he'll um kill some of the
nobles which launches the St. Barflu
days massacre in 1572. Okay, that's a
day when tens of thousands of French
Protestants called Hugenats were killed
and this will start a process by which
these Hugenats extremely well educated,
extremely hardworking, extremely
wealthy, they will move to Protestant
countries like England and the
Netherlands and Germany and they will
help these countries jumpstart the
industrial revolution. Okay, they will
bring their expertise
um and they will help these countries
jumpst start the industrial revolution.
So this is a tremendous loss for France,
tremendous gain for um the other
Protestant
nations. Okay. So um
eventually Europe is divided into two
major factions. The Catholic faction and
the Protestant faction. And these two
factions will eventually engage in
something called the 30 years war. Okay,
between the Hatsburgs, okay, the Holy
Roman Empire was supported by the Pope
versus basically the infinite states of
um Germany. Okay, and this is a war that
will last exactly 30 years and again it
will kill at most 8 million people. It
is the deadliest war in European history
um up until World War I. Uh what's
interesting about this war is that
France, which is Catholic, chooses to
join the Protestants in this war because
they see the Holy Roman Empire as an
imperial threat. They're afraid that if
they allow the Hapsburgs to take over
Germany, then eventually they will
swallow up France. Okay. So, it was a
religious war, but it was also a
geopolitical and imperial war. All
right. And again um this war ends with
the treaty of Westfailia which
guarantees religious freedom in Europe.
Okay. So the the religious wars will end
and Protestant religion will now be free
developed um
independently. Okay. So this is called
the peace of
Westfailia. Okay. So um now let's
summarize and let's um discuss the
evidence for my argument that the
protestant reformation gave birth to
capitalism. Okay. So um these are the
three major differences between the
Catholic religion and the protestant
religion. The question then is why is it
that the north will become really
Protestant and the south of Europe will
become will stay mainly Catholic. Okay.
Um so one thing that we discussed in
this class is the persistence of
culture. So is it so again no one knows
why this is the case. Okay. And you'll
hear different arguments. It could have
been weather. It could have been uh
personality. It it could have been a lot
of different factors. Okay. But one
possibility I I want to present to you
today is the cultural factor which is
that the south of France and the north
of France are culturally different. All
right. So let's look at south of France.
South sorry south of Europe. The
southern Europe countries of Spain,
France and Italy were heavily influenced
by Roman culture. That's where the Roman
Empire was based, right? The Roman
Empire eventually became an imperial
bureaucracy. There are three core values
to the Romans, right? Liberty. Now
liberty, this is really important. It
means obedience to the law. Because only
by obeying the law can people be free to
do what they want. Okay. Second is the
idea of republica. Republica means
public virtue to serve the public good
which basically means obeying what the
Senate tells you to do. Okay? Obeying
authority. And the last is idea of piety
which is to respect the customs and
history and traditions of Rome. Okay.
Okay, so these are the three major
values of the
Romans and we can believe that they're
they become embedded in the south of
Europe. Now let's look at Viking
culture, okay? And when I say Vikings, I
don't really mean Vikings per se. What I
really mean are those protoindo-uropeans
that never really assimilated into Roman
culture, right? So what are their
values? Well, they believe in courage.
They believe in loyalty and they believe
in re resourcefulness. Okay? And we
discussed this when we discussed the
Vikings. Now, what we're going to do is
this. We're going to map Catholic belief
with Romans and we're going to map
Viking belief with the Protestants and
see what happens. Okay. So, the
Catholics, they believe in orthodoxy,
right? Well, the Romans also believe in
orthodoxy. They call it liberty, right?
Obedience to laws. Don't question laws,
just obey them. Um, Catholics believe in
hierarchy. Well, Romans believe in
hierarchy as well. They believe in
obeying the Senate. The Senate is the
ultimate authority, right? Uh Catholics
believe in justification by works. Uh
the Romans believe in piety, right?
Respecting tradition. You don't have to
believe in these traditions, but you
must respect them. All right? So, this
is pretty close. I mean, it's not
perfect. All right? But this suggests
that uh Roman culture had a tremendous
influence on development of the Catholic
Church. Now, let's look at the pro the
Protestants. Okay, they believed in
direct access to God through the Bible.
Well, the Vikings believed in courage.
What is courage? Courage is ex
selfexloration to go out into the
unknown and figure out things for
yourself. Okay? And that's what the
Bible is. That's what faith is. To read
the Bible by yourself and to interpret
the Bible in your own way and you have
to do so using emotional and spiritual
courage. All right. Egotarianism.
So the Vikings had a concept of loyalty
and loyalty is basically the idea of
mutual love. I'm loyal to you and you're
loyal back to me because we love each
other. All right. And the last concept
is justification by faith and individual
struggle to come to terms with what God
means to you individually. Okay. And uh
Vikings believed in resourcefulness,
right? Which is also the idea of
individual struggle. you can figure out
by yourself if you work hard enough, if
you will yourself, you have the courage
to do so. Okay? So again,
um I leave this as a possibility. Okay?
Don't don't treat this as a historical
fact. I just suggest this as a way to
think about why the Protestants became
Protestants, the Catholics became
Catholics. Okay? And a lot of it has to
do with the cultural residue from the
past. Okay? All right. So this this is
just a thought experiment. All right. So
let's talk now talk about why is it that
the Protestant Reformation won out
again. They were up against the R uh the
Holy Roman Empire. They they were up
against Catholic Church. Um there were
more people in Catholic Europe. Catholic
Europe was wealthier and stronger. But
they still won. Okay. And the reason why
they won is due to the invention of
three things. The first thing is the
printing press which allowed for mass
literacy and education. Now everyone
could read the Bible. Before you
couldn't do so, you couldn't afford a
Bible. But now everyone can read the
Bible. But not only that, but but
everyone can now become self-educated.
You can read all the classics by
yourself. Okay? And the Protestant
religion compelled you to be literate
and to be educated. And as such the
Protestants as a whole were more well
educated than the Catholics. Okay,
that's the first reason. Second reason
is the musket. This is really important.
Before uh the main weapon, the ultimate
weapon was the knight, the armor knight.
And the armor knight was a professional
soldier, right? And that's where the
knights were the nobility because you
have to spend all their time uh training
for war, going to war, fighting wars.
Um, and it's very expensive to be a
knight. But now eventually you have the
gun, the musket. Okay? And it takes
about 60 days for anyone to learn how to
use the musket. And the musket is the
thing about the musket that's really
important is it's able to pierce the
armor of the knight, which makes which
makes the knight useless in war. Now,
okay, it's a musket that uh is
important. So in other words, anyone who
has courage and devotion, meaning mainly
the Protestants, they're able to fight a
war and the musket will be vital. It
will be crucial for both the American
Revolution and the French Revolution.
Okay? And we'll we'll discuss the musket
when we get to the American Revolution
and the French Revolution. The last
thing is that of banknotes.
Okay? Before uh people use gold or coins
that were mitted with gold in order to
trade goods. Not only you can use bank
notes which is just money. Okay. Um and
you can now monetize your hard work and
frugality. You can now channel your hard
work and frugality into bank notes.
What's really important now is there's
only a finite number of gold and coins,
right? But there's an infinite source of
banknotes. So you can work infinitely
hard. Okay. So, so what this means is
um before the process reformation, it
was really hard to get people to work
hard because let's just say that you are
an employer and you want to be like,
okay, I'm going to pay people more,
right? But when you pay people more,
they actually work less because they
can't spend that money. They're like,
well, you know, if I have to work eight
hours a day to make $100, but now I work
$2 two hours a day to work to make $100.
I'll just make I'll just make I'll just
work two hours. So we actually work
less. And in this system, slavery makes
sense because
um the way to get people to work hard is
to force them into eternal debt, which
is what slavery is. But in this new
Protestant system, then slavery is an
evil because you're denying people the
capacity to be with God, right? You are
with God if you work hard. But if you're
a slave, how do you measure the hard
work? You you're not able to work hard.
And that's why um after the pos
reformation, one of the main things that
they did was eventually outlaw slavery.
Okay, so there are lots of good things
about about the Protestant Reformation.
You have the industrial revolution. You
have the end of slavery. You have the
rise of capitalism. You have the rise of
the middle class. You have lots of
really good things, but there's also no
denying that there are some bad effects
as well. Okay. All
right. So, this is a printing pressed by
Gutenberg.
This this is what a printing press looks
like. You have the musket. Okay. So,
before people had
bows, right? And the bows um were used
by trained archers and they weren't that
powerful. But now with the musket,
you're able to pierce knight armor.
Okay? Because there's more energy.
uh 3,100 jewels within the
bullet and then you have bank notes as
well and banknotes really is the
exception of wealth. Okay, which means
that in theory now you could have
infinite wealth. Why why are we so
wealthy today? Because we because we
abstracted wealth. Okay, before wealth
was limited because
um gold was limited but now with bank
notes with money in theory wealth can be
infinite.
Okay.
Okay. So this is John Wes Wesley who is
the founder of the Methodist church.
Okay. And he summarizes
the idea of prois Protestantism really
well. We ought not to prevent people
from being diligent and frugal. We must
exhort all Christians to gain all they
can and to save all they can. That is in
effect to grow rich. Right? So
Protestant believe that it is God's
calling. It is your mission to get rich
and that's how you know that you're
favored by God. All right? And the way
to get rich is by working hard and not
spending any money.
Okay. So, what I'm going to do now is
present the evidence for my argument
that the Protestant religion gave birth
to capitalism. Okay. And to do so, I'm
I'm going to refer to three major
thinkers. Max Weber, Eml Durkham, and
Jor Siml. They're all sociologists.
They're considered three major founders
of the social sciences. Okay? And they
they're all contemporaries. They they
were all writing about the year 1900.
Why this is important is the year 1900
is really
when the Protestant religion is most
triumphant. Right? This is when
capitalism is most dominant. Even though
most people are not Protestants,
Protestant um the work ethic, the belief
system has conquered the world.
Germany,
Britain, United States are the are the
three most powerful countries in the
world at this time. They're the three
largest empires and they're all
Protestant nations and as such they can
impose Protestant beliefs on everyone
else. Okay? And in the year 1900 is also
be before World War I. So at this time
everyone thinks that this is the
greatest thing in the world. Protestant
Protestantism, industrial revolution,
capitalism are all um divinely sent by
God to bless humanity. Okay? And what
Max Weber, George Simo, and EML Durkim
are trying to do is figure out what's
really going on. Okay? And to see if
there are any consequences to the
system. And what they will show us is in
fact there are a lot of problems in this
system. Okay. So let's let's first look
at Max Max Weber who in 1904 to 1905
from 1905 he wrote something called the
Protestant ethic and the spirit of
capitalism. He's trying to explain why
is it that protests are a lot wealthier
than Catholics in general. Okay. And
this is what he has to say.
So far as predestination was not
reinterpreted, toned down or
fundamentally abandoned. Okay? So
remember double predestination, right?
The belief that God has already selected
those who will go to heaven and you must
prove to yourself that you're one of
them. Two principal mutually connected
types of pastoral advice appear. Okay?
So there are two consequences to the
idea of predestination.
On the one hand, it is held to be an
absolute duty to consider oneself
chosen. Okay? So, only a minority are
going to heaven. The odds are you're not
going to heaven. But you must believe
you're going to heaven. Otherwise, you
lack faith in God. Otherwise, you don't
truly believe in God. And then and then
therefore, you'll be truly damned,
condemned by God.
and to combat all doubts as temptations
of the devil. Since lack of
self-confidence is the result of
insufficient faith, hence of imperfect
grace. Okay? To prove that God is
perfect, to prove that God loves you,
you must truly believe that you are
chosen by
God. If you doubt yourself, then you'll
be condemned to hell. Okay? Then you
become a servant of the devil. The
exhortation of the apostle to make fast
one's own call is here interpreted as a
duty to attain certainty of one's own
election and certification in the daily
struggle of life. Okay? So you need to
prove that you are one elect by focusing
on this world. Okay? Focus your energies
on conquering this world.
On the other hand, in order to attain
that self-confidence, intense worldly
activity is recommended as the most
suitable means. It and it alone
disperses religious doubt and gives the
certainty of grace. Okay. So this idea
of all the you have anxiety. How do you
deal with anxiety? Work, work, work.
Okay. OCD, obsessive compulsive
behavior. What kind of work do you do?
Make money. Because the money is proof
of God's
grace, right?
Okay. So he
continues there's worldly Protestant
asetism. Okay. Asetism means like you're
actually not spending any money. Okay.
Not only are you compelled to make a lot
of money but you're also compelled not
to spend any of
it, not to enjoy it because that leads
to
corruption that leads to
decadence. Acted powerfully against the
spontaneous enjoyment of possessions. It
restricted consumption especially of
luxuries. Okay. So, no one's spending on
any of this money. Where's this money
going? It's going to the bank. And who's
using this money in the bank? The
government is. And what are they doing?
They're using to fight wars, right? And
that's how England, the Netherlands
became empires. They had access to all
this surplus wealth that Protestants
weren't spending.
On the other hand, it have a
psychological effect of freeing the
acquisition of goods from inhibitions of
traditionalist ethics. Okay. So the idea
here is
this. Before if you're wealthy, you
expected by everyone around you to
support the community, usually by
organizing feasts on religious
festivals. Okay? You were expected to
share your wealth. If you had too much
money, it showed that you were against
the community. Okay? It showed that you
were selfish. But
now people believe that you're if you're
wealthy, it means God favors you. The
more wealth you have, the more people
respect you. Okay? It's a complete
inverse from the historical
um case. Historically we believe that
those who have too much money are evil.
Now we believe that those who have too
much money are inherently good. Okay?
It's complete
reverse. It broke the bonds of the
impulse of acquisition in that it not
only legalized it but looked upon it as
directly willed by God. Okay. So before
it's embarrassing to have too much
money. Now it is prestigious to have too
much money.
The campaign against the temptations of
the flesh and the dependence on external
things was not a struggle against
irrational acquisition but against the
irrational use of wealth. Okay. So
what's evil is not to make a lot of
money. What's evil is to use that money
to enjoy
yourself.
Right? Okay. So now he discusses a
problems with this ideology. Okay. The
Puritan want to work in a calling. Okay.
So the Puritans want to be close to God.
We are forced to do so. We're not
Puritans. Most of the world is not
Puritans. We were stuck. We are in
prison in their world. They create this
world and we're stuck in it. For when
acetism was carried out of monastic
cells into everyday life. Okay. So the
idea was the Catholic Church. If you
wanted to be be aesthetic, if you wanted
to deny the world, you went into a
monastery. The Puritans made the entire
world into a monastery. Okay? Um, and
began to dominate worldly morality. It
did its part in building the tremendous
cosmos of a modern economic order. He's
talking about capitalism. Okay? So,
capitalism was created by the Puritans
in order to rationalize the world.
This order is now bound to the technical
and economic conditions of machine
production which today determine the
lives of all the individuals who are
born into this mechanism. Not only those
directly concerned with economic
acquisition with irristable force. Okay.
So they create this system which is
industrial production. This industrial
production has made us all into slaves
and the soul of this industrial
production system is capitalism. wealth
for the sake of
wealth. Okay? And there's no denying the
system. You cannot you can never free
yourself from the system. You're stuck
inside the system. But not only that,
but this entire of industrial uh
production, it has permeated into all
aspects of life. It's permanent into the
family. It's permanent into the school.
Okay? Why do you have grades? Why do you
have why do we have tests? Because of
this industrial economy, right? grades
tests are another form of
money. Perhaps it will so determine them
until the last ton of fossilized coal is
burnt. Okay? What he's saying here is
that this system will keep on going
until we destroy the planet. Okay? And
until we run out of resources because
that's what capitalism is. It's the
exploitation of the environment.
In Baxter's view, the care for external
goods should only lie on the shoulders
of the saint like a light cloak which
can be thrown aside at any moment. Okay.
So the idea of Protestantism is listen
external
wealth wealth is just a measure of your
faith in God. That's not what's
important. What's important is your
faith, right?
But but the faith decreed that the cloak
should become an iron cage. Okay? Money
was supposed to be a tool. Money was
supposed to be a mechanism for us to
connect with God. But now money,
capitalism, industrial production, it's
become our prison. There's no there's no
denying it. No one can now escape this.
Okay. Okay. Does it make sense to
you? All right. So now he makes
predictions. No one knows who will live
in this cage in the future or whether at
the end of this tremendous development
entirely new profits will arise or there
will be a great rebirth of old ideas and
ideals of e of neither mechanized
petrification embellished with a sort of
convulsive self-importance. Okay, sorry.
I read this wrong. Okay, let let me do
this again. No one knows who will live
in this cage in the future or whether at
the end of this tremendous development
entirely new profits will arise or there
will be a great rebirth of ideas. Okay.
So what we're saying is this as
capitalism conquers more and more
territory as it becomes more embedded
into everyday life. There will be a
nostalgia for the Catholic Church and
there may arise new prophets who will
rebel against capitalism just like
Martin Luther rebelled against the
Catholic religion. Okay? And these new
ideas will happen. They call fascism and
communism. All right? So capitalism will
give rise to the Nazis as well as the
communists, the bullshiks. So this is
the future. Okay? So he's making a
prophecy. But if these things don't
happen then what will happen is
this mechanized petrification
embellished with a sort of convulsive
self-importance. We believe today that
we have achieved divinity. We have
achieved heaven on earth. Capitalism is
the greatest good. But if you think
about it, our civilization has become a
zombie civilization. It is about soul.
It is about spirituality. It is about
heart. It's all machine. It's all money.
It's all obsession. Nothing else. Okay.
So, I'm sorry that this is not appearing
properly. Okay. But but that's what he's
saying here. For of the last stage of
this cultural development, it might well
be truly sad. Specialists without
spirit. Okay. We have scientists who
lack
purpose. They have
no sense of divinity. They have no sense
of mission. Okay? They're just doing
technical work. Scientists who just do
technical
work
sens this nullity imagines that it has
achieved a level of civilization never
before achieved. Okay. All right. So
that's what he's saying. He's saying
like our civilization it is a zombie
civilization. It is an unlimited. No, it
is nothing. Is is nei.
We believe this is
perfection. Okay? And if you think about
it, he's describing perfectly the world
we live in
today. It's perfect. Okay? He's he wrote
this in about 1900. He predicted this
would happen. And he's right. We live in
a zombie
civilization. All right. Okay.
So um this is George Siml who is a
friend of Max Webber's the
contemporaries the colleagues their
friends um and he's trying to explain
where money comes from okay and I as
explained previously money now has
become a substitute for the idea of God
it's become reality itself okay and how
and why is that okay here explains it
the projection of mere relations into
particular objects is one of the great
accomplishments of the mind okay so
we're able to take an idea and transpose
this idea onto a thing. Okay, we're
we're able to take the idea of God and
turn it into money. Okay, we can do that
and that's a great thing. When the mind
is embodied in objects, these become a
vehicle for the mind and endowed with a
livelier and more comprehensive
activity. Okay, when we do this, we turn
God into money. Our understand of
reality becomes much more vibrant. We're
able to understand reality much better.
Okay, the ability to construct such
symbolic objects attains its greatest
triumph in money. Okay, money becomes a
placeholder for everything, right? For
money represents pure interaction, its
purest form. How do we
know if we're working hard? How do we
know if we are succeeding? How do we
know if we have friends through money?
Okay, for capital
accumulation, it makes comprehensible
the most abstract concept. It is an
individual thing whose essential
significance is to reach beyond
individualities. It centralizes
everything. Okay. Everyone agrees on
money. Thus, money is the adequate
expression of the relationship of man to
the world which can only be grasped in
single and concrete instances yet only
really can see when the singular becomes
the embodiment of the living mental
process which interweavves all
singularities and in this fashion
creates reality. Okay. So uh at at the
beginning of the class I talked about
money right how money
um takes all our different perspectives
and converges into one thing okay and
then it redesigns reality through this
lens okay that's what he's saying here
okay uh the last person I want to talk
about is Email Durkham and he's a French
uh sociologist and his most famous book
is called on suicide he's he's trying to
discuss why is it that protestants are
much more likely to kill themselves than
Catholics. Okay. And his
um answer is it's because Protestants
believe you have to struggle
individually with faith whereas
Catholics don't believe that. Catholics
believe that you just follow community
rituals and you're good. Okay. So
Protestants feel that they are alone and
abandoned in this world and that they
they must struggle out of this
darkness and that leads to tremendous
energy. Okay? But it also leads
sometimes to self-deeat. It leads to
hopelessness and that's why they kill
themselves. Okay? So so so let's not
read this but but that's what he's
saying.
Okay. Okay. But I want to read this.
This is really important. He's talking
about the fact that Protestants
transfer this um anxiety in the
accumulation of wealth, right? They're
anxious about what God is. They're
anxious whether or not God loves them
and they uh focus on accumulation of
wealth. Okay? And this is a problem
because overexited ambitions always
exceeds the results that they achieve.
whatever these may be because they have
not been aware that they should not go
any further. Okay. Right. Let's just say
that you want to lose weight. Your
obsession is to lose weight. It's
possible that you may die in the process
because you don't know how much weight
you should lose. You don't know what the
proper equilibrium is. Okay? You just
want to lose as much weight as possible.
That's problem with accumulating money.
You try to get more and more money to
prove your worth to God, but you can't
stop. You don't know when to stop.
Okay?
Consequently, nothing satisfies them and
all this agitation perpetually sustains
itself reaching any form of sity. You
cannot stop. Okay? You look at Jack Ma,
the richest man in China at some point,
right? He has all this money, $50
billion. What is he doing with it?
Nothing. All he wants is make more and
more money. Why? Because only the
acquisition of money brings him
happiness. Nothing else
does. It's a
disease. Above all, as this race towards
an unattainable goal can give no
satisfaction, but the race itself, if
that can be called satisfaction, should
anything chance to get in its way, then
one is left
empty-handed. Okay?
You're so focused on the obainment of
wealth that if you lose this process,
okay, you stop this process, you will
feel devoid of everything. Okay, you
could have $50 billion in the bank, but
you lo you drop out of this race, if you
stop the commission of money, you will
fall into anxiety and
depression.
right now. It so happens that at this
time the struggle becomes more violent
and more painful both because it is less
regulated and because competition is
fiercer. Right? So he's talking about
capitalism. How because it's all about
the creation of wealth and the wealth
can only bring about more anxiety and
more
stress. It's bring it's bringing out all
social bonds. Okay. It's bringing all
traditional morality. It's bringing all
bringing down all customs and
norms. All classes are caught up in it
because there's no longer any
established classification. If you're
rich, if you're poor, you're stuck in
the system. No matter how rich you are,
you're still playing this game. You can
never escape
it. So the effort is all the greater at
the moment when it becomes more
unproductive.
How can the will to live not be weakened
in these conditions? Okay,
so like I know this is hard and I I know
what what what what what I'm saying is
it's going to be depressing, but what
Max Weber is saying is we live in a
zombie
civilization. Okay, that's what he's
saying. What Durkin is saying is that
this civilization is on a on a path to
suicide. It's on a path to
self-destruction because there's no
purpose in a civilization. It's all
this. We exist for the sake of
accumulating nothing of value and
eventually we'll just recognize this and
we'll all have to die. Our civilization
is on a path to suicide. And you know
what? They're right. They're prophets.
Think about this.
Never before in human history have we
been as
wealthy as technological progress right
we have the
internet as more connected we can fly
all around the world you can go to
United States and study and then come
back and work okay you have more
opportunities than ever before but again
think about this okay never before in
human history have there been more
depression anxiety more suicides
ides more feeling of
disconnection.
Okay,
so think about this. Let's do a thought
experiment. Let's just say that I have
anxiety. And the way that I deal with
this anxiety is I collect newspapers.
Every day I'm out collecting newspapers.
I fill this room with newspapers and
then I go next room and I fill up
newspapers. Everyone would say that I am
hoarding. Okay, the word is hoarding and
it is a
disease, right? It's a disease. We all
know, we all know it's a disease. If I
were to go talk to a psychologist, he
would he would say, "I'm I have a
disease. I need I need
to take some anxiety medication. I need
to relax, go on vacation, whatever."
Okay. But let's just say this. Let's
just say I have anxiety and all I want
to do is make money. I make a million
dollars. I don't spend it. I put in the
bank and I go make $2 million.
and then I go make $300 and I'm not
spending it. It's all in the bank. Okay.
How is that different from hoarding?
How's that different from me collecting
newspapers and just putting in the
house? It's not. There's no difference,
right?
But everyone would think I'm a great
person. I am a good person because I'm
working hard and I'm saving money.
Right? It's a contradiction in our
society. It's a contradiction that
exists because our society, our
civilization is incapable of recognizing
that we are a zombie civilization that
is on the path to civilizational
suicide. All
right. Okay. So, this was depressing,
but I feel as
though we needed to
um discuss this. Okay. And again um the
same ideas that we learned previously
we're combining it and and we are going
to use these ideas to understand the
future development. Okay. All right. So
um any questions?
Great.
Yep.
believe that.
Okay, you're absolutely right. Okay,
you're absolutely right that that so in
the Catholic religion, suicide is the
worst sin that you can commit. Okay, and
in the Protestant religion, there are
also um mechanisms against suicide. But
let's go back to the theory. The theory
is double predestination. God has
already decided who will be burned in
hell and who will go to heaven and only
a minority can go to heaven right and
there's nothing you can do to change
this you understand so if you follow the
logic you commit suicide you're doing
God's will because you commit suicide
because you don't believe in God or you
don't have enough faith in God which
means that you were condemned anyway
okay so suicide it's not a sin it's a
sign of weakness
Does that make
sense?
Okay. But um also what's important for
us to remember is that suicide, it's
also a feeling of
disconnection. It's a belief that no one
cares if you die or not. No one supports
you in your life and therefore you're
better off dead. When you if you die,
you're not actually impacting the
community. Okay?
And that's I Durkham's argument. You're
always going to have people kill
themselves in all religions. There's you
can't really stop that. But Protestants
are more likely to kill themselves
because Protestant is a much more
individualistic uh religion than
Catholic.
Okay. All right. Does that make sense?
Great.
Okay. Next question.
philosophers.
Okay, so these three are not
philosophers. These three are
sociologists. So they're social
scientists. They're Max Weber who was
consider the founder of sociology. Uh
Jor Siml um and Durkham. These these are
the three major sociologists that uh
really um created modern social
sciences. Okay.
a lot of
problems. Do they have any idea?
Okay, that's a great question. Okay. Um,
okay. So, these are social scientists
and the thing about social scientists is
they feel their responsibility is to
diagnose problems and once they diagnose
problems then it's up to us to figure
out the solution. Okay. So, so, so let's
let's figure out what they're saying.
Okay, so um Weber is saying
that this
anxiety which leads to
capitalism will ultimately lead to
civilizational
decline. Okay, that's his main argument.
Okay. So again like he's not writing at
the beginning of Protestantism where
protest was a persecuted religion
um and where um it really gave hope to a
lot of people and it it really empowered
them to transform their lives. Okay.
He's really talking about late
protestism when it's really conquered
the world and he he's seeing a lot of
issues. Okay. And so he's looking at
this. He's looking at the anxiety which
causes capitalism which causes
civilization to decline. So he says
there has to be a response. And there's
going to be pos three possible
responses. Okay? The first possible
response is nothingness. Okay? In which
case, guess what? We we become a zombie
society. A zombie society just means
that we just go on daytoday doing
whatever, but we don't know why. We
don't really care. We have no soul. We
have no spirit. We have no energy. Okay,
that's what a zombie society is. And
that and that's what he's afraid of. But
it's also possible that there is a uh
reaction, okay, which will lead to the
return of the Catholic Church, which was
basically a
theocracy. Does that make sense? That's
the second possibility. Now another
possibility is that you have new
profits or people who are trying to
channel this discontent with capitalism
in order to form new movements in the
way that Martin Luther and John Calvin
did. Right? And in the 20th century
there were two major responses to the
problem capitalism. The first of course
is called
communism. The second is called fascism,
okay? Or the
Nazis. All right? So the 20th century
was really about
defeating these two critics of
capitalism, right? That's what the 20th
century really was about. You first had
World War II, which defeated Nazism, and
you have the Cold War, which defeated
communism. All right? So this is out.
Okay. So right now, okay, our two our
two paths ahead of us is either a zombie
society or the or a return to a
theocracy. And so if I'm a betting man
what a future looks like, I think it is
most likely the world becomes a
theocracy. All right? And there are
theocracies that exist today. So for
example, let's look at North Korea.
North Korea is a theocracy where people
are not allowed to think for themselves.
People must do what they're told. Okay?
And it's all a very heavily ritualized
society which worships the divinity of
the supreme
leader. We may hate the society. We may
be disgusted by by the society. But
guess what? Okay, this is really
important. People in North Korea, even
though they're poorer, even though they
have less freedom, they are on average
happier and more fulfilled and more
energetic.
than most societies. You compare you
compare North Korea with South Korea.
Okay? Right? In South Korea, no one's
having
kids. That's a sign of complete
hopelessness in their society. North
Korea, they're having a lot of kids.
That's a sort of faith in our society.
Okay? So, that's what Max Weber is
predicting. He's predicting these three
possible paths. We tried the new
prophets path, didn't work. Okay? We
don't want to become a zombie society.
So the only path ahead of us is to
become a
theocracy, a return to the tyranny of
the Catholic Church. But the tyranny
gives us meaning, purpose, and
spirituality, a connection with God that
we are lacking into this into today's
society. Okay. But okay, let's just say
for the sake of argument, you know what?
Um, I like my individual freedom, right?
All right. I don't want to I don't want
to go to to a bureaucracy where
everyone's a slave. What can we do about
this?
Um, okay. So, one issue that Max Weber
doesn't really address because he
doesn't recognize the problem is all
these problems we're talking about is a
problem of mass
society. Okay.
When you have mass society, your options
are much more limited. When you have
mass society, you need to feed millions
and millions of people. You need to
organize them. You need to give some
something to do. Therefore, your
political flexibility doesn't really
exist. Okay? So, in other words, okay,
thinking ahead, there are two solutions.
either you become a theocracy or you
figure out the problem of not society.
Okay, if society
becomes I mean like I'm sorry to say
this but like if most people in the
world died then we would have more
freedom in this world. Okay, but if but
if we choose to continue the system we
have 8 billion people struggling on this
earth then you're stuck with moving
towards a theocracy.
Okay. So that's what Max Weber is
saying. He's basically
um giving us a prophecy about our future
right now. Okay. Having said
that, let's look
at Durkham. Okay.
Durkham. What's he
saying? He's saying this. Okay. This is
really important. Okay. Um it's a hard
argument but this is what he's saying.
All right. Why do you have
suicide? Su suicide is result of
disconnection. If we do not think we are
valuable in the world. If we think that
we are alone in this world, we don't
want to be part of this world. We kill
ourselves. Okay. It's a very simple
idea, right? But then the question then
is why is your
disconnection? Because of anxiety,
right?
It's it's a belief that if I don't work
hard, God will not favor
me. Right? Why is anxiety important?
Because it leads to
capitalism. So in other
words, these four concepts are
interconnected. All right? Disconnection
leads to suicide. But we have
disconnection because of anxiety. But
anxiety is what feeds capitalism. If
people weren't anxious, they wouldn't go
out and work so hard to make money,
right? To be like, you know what? I'm
very happy making my $10 a day and sat
at home eating noodles because I don't
care, right? Your society would
collapse. Capitalism will
collapse. Okay? So, so you understand
capitalism creates suicide. That's why
we have the highest suicide rate in the
whole in in in entirety of human
history. Okay. More anxiety, more
depression, more suicide, more
unhappiness, more loneliness than ever
before in human history.
Okay? So, you can't say capitalis
capitalism is the issue. But if you work
out the logic, capitalism is the
issue, right? And that's why today in
the United States and elsewhere in the
world, they're talking about a return to
a theocracy because that the direct
response to capitalism is a theocracy.
Let's just all obey the church and we're
good. Okay. Now, women will have to stay
at home and uh give birth to kids. Oh,
and also like if you're homosexual,
we're we're going to have to kill you.
But, you know, that's the price we we're
going to have to pay. Okay. So, it's a
terrible world that we're going to. But
what Durkin is saying is if we continue
on the path of capitalism, people are
going to choose the path of theocracy
that theocy theocracy is almost the
natural outcome of capitalism because of
the problem of
disconnection. Okay, but are you going
to be able to defeat capitalism ever?
And the answer is no. Okay, we tried in
the 20th century. It led to the death of
tens of millions of people. Okay, good
luck trying to defeat
capitalism. You can't do it. It can't be
done. It's too
powerful.
Okay, does that make sense?
Okay, any more questions?
Okay, great. So,
um, next Tuesday we do the silent
revolution. Okay. All right.